match on a stick two hydrogen Big Bang
coming
you ready here here we go
hydrogen is the lightest element and
it's also very in Bandhan tellement you
find it throughout the universe it's in
stars in the space between stars and of
course on earth so here's our little
Hindenburg yet a nice shiny balloon with
a very very flammable coating and we're
just going to pop it onto the cylinder
here and fill it up with a blast of
hydrogen so you can probably hear it
hissing and fizzing into the bottle
there you know I think that it's also
part of one of the most complex and
interesting molecules that there exists
and that's water and there's still so
much that we don't understand about
water and as time goes on I think that
water will become more and more
important okay so there's a balloon and
as you can see it's quite floating you
know so gotta keep hold of it are you
moving it you know hydrogen is part of
water because water has the formula h2o
so you can look at it as the oxide of
hydrogen or the hydride of oxygen but it
is the hydrogen that is particularly
important and it's interaction with
oxygen in the molecule the other thing
about hydrogen which really fascinates
chemists is that it has an isotope
deuterium which weighs twice as much
which is an enormous difference in mass
so by doing the same experiment with
deuterium instead of hydrogen you can
get very different effects reactions go
faster or reactions go slower depending
what the role of the hydrogen or
deuterium is Oh fantastic apart from
their weight they would look much the
same a heavy water d2o looks much the
same as h2o but it has a slightly
different boiling point slightly
different freezing points but if you
start measuring its properties for
example looking the way that it absorbs
infrared light the way that molecules
react with it then it turns out to be
very different
the difference between the isotopes is
that in hydrogen the nucleus contains
just one proton and the in deuterium the
nucleus contains both a proton and a
neutron the neutron has the same mass of
a proton at least within for this
purposes and so the Nutri the nucleus of
hydrogen weighs half that of deuterium
there is a third isotope of hydrogen
called tritium
which has one proton and two neutrons
and that's radioactive so so what we've
got here is you've got these balloons
full of hydrogen and the air around it
it's full of oxygen a little bit of
nitrogen in there you know but the
oxygen that's the magic stuff so it
forms a really nice intimate mixture and
what we're going to do is we're just
going to offer it a match we're going to
see if it gets pop match on a stick to
hydrogen Big Bang coming you ready yep
here we go
you